THE STATE OF ALASKA.
>> Dana: CHANGES ARE AFOOT
INDEED.
THANK YOU.
GOVERNORS ARE TELLING BUSINESSES
WHEN THEY CAN REOPEN BUT IT’S UP
TO THE BUSINESS OWNER WHETHER TO
OPEN OR NOT.
WHITE HOUSE ECONOMIC ADVISOR
LARRY KUDLOW SAYS BUSINESSES
WITH THE OPTION OPEN RIGHT NOW
SHOULD NOT BE LIABLE IF THEY
CONTRACT CORONAVIRUS AFTER THEY
REOPEN.
LET’S BRING IN FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR AND FORMER ASSISTANT
U.S. ATTORNEY AND THIS CAUGHT MY
EYE YESTERDAY THAT LARRY KUDLOW
SAID THAT AND DAN McLAUGHLIN,
ONE OF YOUR COWRITERS AND
COLLEAGUES AT NATIONAL REVIEW
BASICALLY SAYING MORE LAWSUIT
PROTECTION FOR THESE BUSINESSES
MEANS FASTER REOPENING COME UP
WITH THE LAWMAKERS WOULD HAVE TO
MAKE SOME OF THESE CHANGES, AND
I WONDER WHAT YOU THINK ABOUT
THIS.
>> I THINK THERE’S A CASE TO BE
MADE FOR IMMUNITY FOR BUSINESSES
ESPECIALLY IF WE WANT TO
ENCOURAGE THEM TO REOPEN.
I’M VERY SUSPICIOUS OF THE IDEA
OF A SWEEPING ONE, AND THIS
SEEMS TO ME TO BE THE SORT OF
THING THAT’S WHY WE HAVE
CONGRESSIONAL HEARINGS BEFORE WE
DO THIS KIND OF LEGISLATION.
NO ONE WANTS TO SEE THE
BUSINESSES OBJECTED TO FRIVOLOUS
LAWSUITS UNDER CIRCUMSTANCES
WHERE THEY ARE FOLLOWING GOOD
BUSINESS PRACTICES AND SOMEONE
WHO WORKS FOR THEM CONTRACT THE
DISEASE.
ON THE OTHER HAND, I THINK
PEOPLE WOULD BE UNCOMFORTABLE
WITH THE IDEA OF IMMUNITY IF THE
BUSINESS WERE FORCING ITS
EMPLOYEES OR CONVERSING COERCING
ENGAGE IN BEHAVIORS THAT ARE
LIKELY TO UP THE SPREAD OF THE
DISEASE SO I THINK THAT’S ALL
GOT TO BE WORKED OUT, BUT I
THINK IT’S THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
IN THERE JUST HAS TO BE SOME
LIMITATIONS.
>> Dana: IT’S A COMPLEX ISSUE.
THE OTHER THING I WANTED TO TALK
ABOUT IS THIS IDEA OF THE
CONTACT TRACING AND THE
SURVEILLANCE FEELING THAT IT
GIVES TO SOME PEOPLE.
LISTEN TO GOVERNOR NEWSOM OF
CALIFORNIA ABOUT WHAT HE IS
PLANNING.
>> WE IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
HAVE A LONG HISTORY OF TESTING
AND TRACKING AND TRACING
PATIENTS.
YOU LOOK AT AGGREGATED DATA SET
THAT WILL ALLOW US TO TRACK THE
TRACING.
>> Dana: ALL RIGHT, I THINK
THAT THIS IS WELL-INTENTIONED,
BUT THERE ARE SOME LEGAL
CONCERNS.
YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> THERE’S A LOT OF LEGAL
CONCERNS WITH ALL OF THE STUFF
ACROSS THE BOARD AND I THINK WE
COULD DO A LOT BETTER ON THIS IF
WE JUST GOT THE BURDEN OF PROOF
RIGHT.
WE REMEMBERED IN EVERY ONE OF
THESE INSTANCES WHERE WE HAVE
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHTS RUBBING UP
AGAINST SOMETHING THE GOVERNMENT
IS ENTITLED TO REGULATE LIKE
PREVENTING THE SPREAD OF
INFECTIOUS DISEASE, IF WE WERE
TO REMEMBER THAT THE DEFAULT
CONDITION IS WE HAVE OUR
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHTS AND THAT IT’S
THE GOVERNMENT’S BURDEN TO SHOW
THAT A RESTRICTION THAT THEY
WANT TO IMPOSE IS RATIONALLY
RELATED TO PUBLIC HEALTH AND
IT’S SOMETHING THAT NEEDS TO BE
DONE IN ORDER TO BLUNT THE
SPREAD OF THE DISEASE, I THINK
WOULD BE IN A LOT BETTER SHAPE
THAN WHAT WE HAVE NOW WHICH IS
THE ASSUMPTION BY THESE
GOVERNMENTS THAT THEIR
REGULATION IS WHAT HAS PRIORITY
AND MAY HAVE TO ADJUST OUR
EXPECTATIONS ABOUT OUR
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHTS TO WHAT THEY
THINK IS NECESSARY OR ESSENTIAL.
>> Dana: WE KNOW THAT APPLE
AND GOOGLE ARE WORKING ON THAT
APP AND WHAT IF YOUR EMPLOYERS
REQUIRED YOU TO DOWNLOAD THE APP
BEFORE YOU COULD COME BACK TO
WORK?
WOULD YOU HAVE TO DO IT?
>> THAT WOULD BE A CONDITION OF
YOUR EMPLOYMENT, THAT’S VERY
DIFFERENT THAN IF THE GOVERNMENT
WERE TO COERCE YOU TO DO IT.
I THINK OF AN EMPLOYER WANTS TO
REQUIRE THAT AS A CONDITION,
THAT’S A PRIVATE EMPLOYER, THAT
SEEMS OKAY TO ME.
BUT I’D BE MORE CONCERNED ABOUT
IS THE GOVERNMENT, WAREHOUSING
THIS INFORMATION AND USING THE
SURVEILLANCE FOR PURPOSES OTHER
THAN PUBLIC HEALTH, AND I THINK
YOU COULD BE ASSUAGED BY A LOT
OF THAT IF YOU DIDN’T HAVE
GOVERNOR SAYING THINGS LIKE THE
BILL OF RIGHTS IS ABOVE MY PAY
GRADE.
>> Dana: THAT GOVERNOR MURPHY
SAID THAT.
>> YES.
MY GOVERNOR.
I THINK HE IS DOING A VERY
GOOD JOB, BY THE WAY.
HE’S DOING A VERY GOOD JOB, BUT
YEAH.
>> Dana: I DON’T THINK IT’S